Google is one of the most successful search engines in the world.
The Silicon Valley giant is now in the business of selling phones.
Mario Quieroz is Google's Vice President of Product Management.
We're announcing the Nexus One.
The Nexus One is not just another smartphone.
Google describes it as a super phone that consumers can buy without first having to subscribe...
...to a service provider.
And Nexus One is where Web meets phone.
Among the highlights of this pocket-size computer:...
...3D visual effects and a 5 megapixel camera with flash.
The Nexus One also contains voice recognition technology...
...so users can compose e-mails with their voice.
Sounds good, period.
Where are we meeting, question mark.
The phone is actually manufactured by the Taiwan-based company, HTC.
Google creates the operating system called, Android.
Nexus One is not the first mobile device to use Google's Android.
A little over a year ago, we had one device on one carrier in one country.
And since that time, we can now count more than 20 devices on 59 carriers...
...in 48 countries, in 19 languages.